Listen,
this is probably the most difficult
poem that we'll be reading all semester.
Um, but as I mentioned briefly in
the, in the last class, the, this,
the notorious difficulties attending this,
this poem seem to have very little to
do with Milton's grief over the death of
Edward King, which, which may well not
have been all that troubled, uh, or,
or a co or complicated. We
have no, we have no evidence.
And I mentioned this before,
that there was a particularly close
relation between these two young men. Uh,
the difficulty of the poem
lies to a great degree, I think
in something that Dr. Johnson had noted
in his attack or in his criticism on
listen to us that, that I, that I
mentioned on Monday, it's difficult.
It's difficult to lies in Milton's
tendency in this poem to seek out what
wonderfully Dr. Johnson
calls remote illusions.
The,
um,
this is by far the most learned and the
most demanding lyric poem that Milton
Rights. It's a home deeply invested in
the tradition of, of, of pastoral poetry,
pastoral poetry from a
theocracy and virginal onward.
It's a palm deeply invested.
In fact,
in the entire Western tradition
of poetry in general. And,
and finally,
I think it can be said that it's a poem
who's deepest investment is actually in
Milton's mastery over the entire
Western tradition of literature.
Milton, and this is, this
will be the working assumption
that I bring to this. Uh,
my,
I bring to my reading of,
of this poem Milton sets out to prove
something enlisted us and the most
important thing that he proves his,
his control over the learning
that he has accumulated.
Now, I spoke last time of that
familiar sense of, of hesitation,
that apology with which Milton
had opened the elegy. Um, we, we,
we hear in the 1637 listen to us,
those same cries of unrighteousness and
underprepared preparation that we had
heard in the, in the 1631
Sonnet, how soon? Half the time,
the subtle piece of youth
when Milton opens listed us with
it. That phrase, yet once more,
one of the things that he's telling
the reader is that yet, once more,
yet once more, he'll be making
the same argument for unreadiness.
The same argument for nervous anticipation
that he's made a number of times
before.
And so as a way of understanding the,
what at this point is really the sheer
repetitiveness repetitiveness of this
disclaimer, I want to propose,
I want to propose a metaphor.
I propose that we think of Milton at
the opening of Lucentis as being stuck,
stuck at a particular
point in the imagined,
the projected or fantasize
trajectory of his career. And He,
and I'm using the word stuck of course,
because the lady had been stuck. Uh, so,
so, so famously and so
prominently in Comas. Uh, you,
you may remember that I had suggested
in the lecture on the Nativity, Yo,
that Milton may have thought of his career
as if it were something like a race.
And I think here that the particular
image of a career as a race still still
holds, uh, but with a little bit of
a difference. What seems so obvious,
at least to me here in
reading lists of this,
is that at this point in 1637,
there's a stumbling block or a hurdle
that Milton in his race simply can't get
over. No. The, the, the surest
sign of a hurdle is, is,
uh,
is one of those pointed literary
illusions that Milton makes enlisted us,
one of those remote illusions that
Johnson had complained about and it's an
illusion that has everything to do with
Milton's own sense of his unreadiness
and I'm thinking of that. Oh,
it's just, it's wonderful.
That strange moment that happens
fairly early on in the poem.
This is line 76 in the Hughes edition,
it's page 122.
Okay.
It's that moment in which Phoebus
Apollo makes a sudden and unexpected
appearance and then now not only does
feed this Apollo make a sudden appearance,
but he seems actually to interrupt the
speaker of the poem in order to correct
him now. So, so we'll, we'll let, let's
remind ourselves what's been happening.
Milton has just been lamenting the
fact that the laborious days of the,
of the poet might not result in a
sudden blaze of fame. What good is it?
You'll remember what good is it?
Milton has to tend the high
homely slided shepherds trade.
That's of course the vocation of poetry.
It's that shepherd poet is just going
to be struck down in his prime is Edward
King.
Had been.
And you'll remember that
Milton had complained that
the thin spun life could be
so easily slipped. But,
but look at line 76.
Yeah,
but not the praise.
Phoebus replied and
touched my trembling ears.
Okay. Uh, what, what's
happened? Uh, Vivas Apollo,
the god of the sun and not
unimportantly also the god of poetry.
He was Apollo bursts into the
text and correct the poet.
Correct. The poet's youthful
interest in earthly fame.
Fame is no plant that grows on mortal
soil. True fame exists only in heaven.
The only reputation that matters is the
praise you ultimately receive from God
or all judging jove as he
pronounces. Lastly, on each deed,
and as in all of these early
lyrics, jove, uh, conventionally,
throughout the renaissance,
um, is, is used as a,
as a name within these
classical fictions, uh, to, to,
to signify the Christian God.
Now this moment is striking
in part because we had no
idea how could we possibly
have had an idea that FIBA is,
Apollo was actually eaves
dropping on the poet's discourse.
I think we're taken aback here.
Were taken aback by the, the,
the rude interruption in the otherwise
seamless flow of the poets lament.
But the poet, the, the, the,
this moment is also striking
because Milton has lifted it,
lifted this entire scene of this
interruption from somewhere else.
He has taken it from one of the
pastoral poems, a Virgil, the, the,
the image of a poet interrupted and
chided by the god of poetry comes straight
out of the opening of Virgil's
six ECT Gluck. And Virgil was,
Virgil had written a poem in the six
that clog that had touched Melton and it
had touched Milton I think because
it begins with Virgil's own brooding
meditation on the course
of his poetic career.
Now we all know what Virgil's poetic
career would go on to look like.
Virtual would go on to
be a great epic poet. Um,
but not until after he had written these
pastoral at blogs. And then after that,
after he had written the Georgic poems,
only then does he write finally
the great epic poem, the Aeneid.
Now in Virgil's early
poem, this, this six blog,
the speaker explains that the writing
of pastoral poetry is this stuff that,
that young poets do.
Poets begin their careers
with easy pastoral poems, but,
but virtual speaker says that he's
more ambitious. Now he's starting to,
to champ at the bit.
He's ready to write an epic poem on much
more important subjects then that then
shepherds and shepherdess is he
wants to write about kings and wars.
And as soon as he has expressed
this epic ambition, uh,
virtual explains, as soon as he's
expressed this Phoebus Apollo,
the god of poetry stepped in
and chided him. So this is, uh,
this is virtual.
When I was feigned to sing of
kings and battles the Sinthian God,
that's Phoebus Apollo
plucked my ear and warned me.
Apollo warns Virgil that a pastoral poet
simply shouldn't overstep his bounds.
Uh, this is the Virgil,
he should sing thin,
little find spawn maize and he should
be content feeding is fat sheep.
The God told Virgil that he wasn't
ready yet for the manly, the adult,
uh, the public world, the
important world of epic poetry.
And so all of this anxiety, and when
you think of it, all of this shame,
uh, and, and, and as well as
the, the shame of ambition,
all of this gets packed into this illusion
to Virgil that Milton brings to this
very disturbing moment enlisted us.
And it's important I think that this
Virgilian scene with Apollo appears so
early in Milton's.
Milton's listed has Milton's
of this doesn't end up all
soaked in this unhealthy
brew of neurotic brew of anxiety
and shame and naked and ambition.
And I think it's one of our jobs here
to figure out why that's the why that's
the case. Why doesn't, this is
one way of putting the question,
why doesn't Apollo harass or bother
Milton at the end of Lucentis in the same
way that he arrests as Milton
at the poems beginning.
Now I,
um,
I think you may be rather happy to
hear that this is the last time.
I'm pretty sure that this is the last
time that we will have to discuss at least
at any length.
Milton's worries about his unreadiness
and his and his and preparation. It's,
it's safe to say that,
listen,
this is one of the last poetic works
of Milton's that's really consumed with
this problem,
the problem of fruitless anticipation
and in some ways I think that that's
because the poem was it us seems in some
ways to solve the problem of Milton's
weightings and this problem
that he has a meeting to wait.
And so one of the things that
needs to be explored here is why.
Why this poem is the last poem that
Milton is not prepared to write.
What does Milton do? This is,
this is what I see as our project,
our interpretive project.
As we approached this poem,
what is Milton do to get himself
unstuck from this seat of anxious,
anxious,
anticipation?
That's the project.
So we looked,
we looked last time at the,
at the oddity that peculiarity
of Milton's choice of genre here,
the pastorals genre.
Milton was the only Cambridge poet
to honor Edward King in that memorial
anthology by writing a poem
in the pastoral mode and and,
and a and a pastoral of course
features shepherds and shepherd as, as,
as it's most distinguishing
characteristic.
The word pastoral comes from
the Latin Pastore store,
which literally means shepherd and Ulta
knew perfectly well how artificial his
use of the pastoral mode of poetry would
seem. And as well as how out of fashion,
how completely outdated it would seem.
But one of the motives
for a selection of this,
John or the pastoral
genre is the tradition and
institution that goes all the
way back to theocracy and Virgil
that associates shepherds with poets,
and this has always been a part of the
pastoral genre to speak of shepherds and
shepherding.
And a pastoral poem seems
almost invariably to a
strategy or a way to speak of
poets and their craft of poetry.
This is,
this is a kind of literary
self consciousness that, that,
that we're all familiar with.
But there's another meaning
given to shepherds as well.
After the longs way of the awkwardness is,
and Virgil's pastorals of course,
Christianity entered the scene,
a new dispensation and Christianity
began to load this pastoral literary
tradition with its own set
of associations. Shepherds
came to resent you.
Separate came to represent not only poets,
they came to stand for ministers.
They came to signify allegorically
ministers as well. So priests,
ministers or pastors,
we still call them pastors,
had long been referred to as as shepherds,
they are leaders of their flocks.
And so it seemed a natural move for early
Christian writers to use this existing
pastoral form when they wanted to
speak on the subject of, of, of,
of priests or ministers
or affairs of the church.
So Milton is essentially inheriting
both of these traditions,
both of these sets of associations with
costs, with pastoral poetry, and, and we,
when we consider the particular
circumstances that occasioned the poem,
listen it. So we can see why
Milton I think chose this
pastoral form. Edward King,
the, uh, the, the young man,
the [inaudible] deceased was a minor
poet on his way to begin his career as a
minister. And the, and the
figure of the shepherd,
the past store fuses into one person
or into one w one figurative entity.
Both of these callings,
the vocation of the poet and the
vocation of the minister. We've looked,
we've looked before it,
Milton's reason of church government.
That's the political treatise written
in 1642 and we've seen Milton's account
thereof of how he had attempted
to reconcile on the one hand,
his obligation to become a minister and
his desire on the other hand to become a
poet. Um, but I, I want to back up
now because I think it's important,
uh,
to fill in a little bit of the historical
context behind that long but important
pros. Treatus it's not a, it's not
irrelevant to our understanding of,
of listeners.
The subject of the reason of church
government is the hierarchical Milton's
feelings about the hierarchical structure
of the Church of England in the early
years of the English revolution,
one of the hottest flashpoints of,
of political contention was the,
what's the degree of appropriate
state involvement in the church?
And as with almost all of the issues of
contemporary and political struggle in
the 17th century, Milton's own views
really fall decidedly to the left,
to the progressive end of the political
spectrum. And so beginning in the late,
late, late 1630s, when at
the, at the moment in which
listed us as being written,
Milton is becoming increasingly
radical and we can think of it,
I mean this is an acronystic term,
but increasingly leftist and he's becoming
one of those figures that we can now
identify with this label of Puritan.
Yeah.
Puritans at this moment in English
history, replacing more and more emphasis
when thinking about how things should,
uh,
yeah,
work at church more and
more emphasis on the sermon.
The institution of the sermon,
the act of preaching sermons for puritans
was becoming more important actually
than following the ceremonial rituals
of the, uh, of the Church of England.
So when the years just before 1637, the
English court, uh, under James the first,
and then later under Charles the
first, uh, the, the, uh, the,
the English crown had been cracking down
on the delivery of puritan sermons in
the church. It's 1633, um,
William law had been appointed the,
the Archbishop of Canterbury,
and he had been granted an extraordinary
set of arbitrary powers of suppression
actually, uh, by the
monarch. And his mission,
Lord took his mission as the head
of the Church of England to be
the squelching have this
puritan opposition. And, and,
and the most outrageous action in Lodz
crackdown was his move to ban his attempt
to ban preaching, uh, in, in, in churches.
So under archbishop laud
only the official liturgy,
it could be recited in church. As you can
imagine, there's, uh, there's, there's,
this was controversial, uh, a
struggle breaks out in the church.
And Milton naturally takes the puritan
position in favor of preaching.
The church shouldn't be under
the control of the bishops.
This is Milton's argument or prelates a
common 17th century word for admissions.
But the church should be led by preachers,
men who were chosen by their
congregations to preach.
And eventually this is where we get
the notion of, of congregationalism.
So given all of the controversies
raging around the question of the proper
government of the church,
and Milton is deeply invested in these,
in these matters,
Milton Milton feels obliged
to do something. And, and,
and this is the,
this is one of the reasons that he
writes the reason of church government,
this intense sense of,
of obligation that he feels he feels duty
bound to participate materially rather
than in this, in this, uh,
political and the political controversy
rather than merely remaining in his
studious retirement, however pleasant
that is at his father's house.
And were Milton not to, to fight in some
way to defend when he takes to be the,
to church. He would simply
not be investing those talents
that God had given him.
This is the, this is the miltonic logic
that we're, that we're familiar with.
So this is the situation that Milton finds
himself in as he's riding. Listen us,
he's under the greatest pressure of his
life to do something with his talent.
He wants,
of course,
at least we assume that he's still
want that he wants to be a poet.
But at the same time,
he fears that being a poet means,
and this is a fear that literate young
men and women have have to this very day
to be a poet means in some way not to
be acting responsibly or or politically
soso. Milton explains in the reason
of church government, he tries to,
he tries to mend this breach
and so we argues in the,
in this treatise that po poetry has,
and I'm quoting him here,
poetry has a power beside
the office of the pulpit.
Milton even claims that poetry is equal
to preaching and its ability to move
people, to get them to do
something, to make things
happen in the world. Of course,
this is a lot of pressure to put on
poetry and it's especially in a lot of
pressure to put on a pastoral log
that's ostensibly about shepherds,
[inaudible],
shepherds and sheep,
but it is the duty of this poem lists
of this to show that poetry can exert a
power beside the office of the pulpit,
that it can do the same kind of work
that a preacher is able to accomplish
behind the behind the pulpit.
Milton has to develop a poetic voice
that can actually combine those two
vocations that the two offices,
the though the office of poetry
and the Office of Ministry.
And if we want to think of it in, in the,
in the more familiar domestic context,
uh,
Milton has to begin a career that can
please both himself and his and his
father. Now, last time when I,
I mentioned the dramatic
structure of this poem,
you'll remember it
features a succession of,
of four mourners and each of these and
mourners we could think of each of these
mourners providing Milton with an
opportunity to try out a different voice.
But one of the voices
utterly mops the floor with,
with, with all of the others. Um,
it stands far outside that certainly it
stands outside the generally pastoral
framework of, of the poem.
Uh, the most striking,
the most powerful of all of the morning
morning voices here is that of Saint
Peter.
This is the figure that Milton refers
to in line 109 as the pilot of the
Galilean Lake.
Now what Saint Peter doing in this poem,
the very mention of Saint
Peter naturally violates the,
the classical pastoral fiction
of, of the poem. Up to this point,
the Christian God has
been referred to as Joe.
That's how the poem works since
it's within the pagan world,
the pagan fictional world of the classical
pastoral that this Christian poem is,
is set,
but to speak both of Jove and of Christ
is obviously in some ways to mix your
metaphors and, and, and,
and the effect can only be disorienting
that the character of Peter, uh,
brought directly out of the New Testament.
It's really slicing through the poems
victim veneer and Peter Cutts a figure so
daunting and so terrifying that were
almost led to forget that the poem where
reading is a pastoral LG at all.
So unbelievable is Peter's discourse.
Okay.
Line 109.
Okay,
last came in.
Last did go the pilot of the
Galilean link to Massey keys.
He bore of Metals Twain, the golden
opes. The iron shuts the main,
he shook his mitered blocks
and stern bisque bake.
Now this is important to Milton.
This is decidedly the last
of all the funeral mourners.
And Peter Provides Milton's poem
with an important element of,
of finality of have closure.
Peter wields the keys of the Kingdom of
Heaven and can open and shut the doors
at personal salvation just as he can
open and shut the doors of the church.
But it's the,
that's his function,
but it's the sentiments that Peter Routers
that I think most powerfully grab us
and they grab us because
they are so angry.
They're so violent in their anger
as the head of the true church.
Peter's voicing here his disgust that
the virtuous Edward King soon to become a
minister had been lost at sea.
Okay.
Think of the logic of
what Peter is saying here.
He would gladly have traded dozens.
He would have traded dozens of corrupt
Anglican ministers for the simple and
honest king.
Look at line one 13 this is where Peter
is addressing Edward King himself.
How well could I have spared for the
young Swain enough of such as for their
bellies sake, creep and intrude
and climbing to the fold.
Th the corrupt clergy up today,
the under the Mullein influence of the
horrible archbishop laud are interested
only in satisfying their own grief. And,
and in order to fill their own bellies.
So greedy or they, they, they
intruded into the churches,
fold and devour for themselves.
This is how the allegory works,
devour for themselves the nourishment
that of course they should be sharing with
their flock,
but this wish that this wish that other
shepherds had died and not Edward King
is, is so strange. You
can't deny it. And it's,
there is something here of a
kind of in decorous tone of,
of malice that the priests and the
prevalence of the church are so corrupt
according to,
uh,
according to Saint Peter that we're led
to assume almost not that this is the
direct charge, but implicitly I think
this is what Peter is conveying.
It's almost as if they're responsible
for Edward King's as if by creeping into
the churches fold,
somehow they've managed to
push poor Edward King out
of the fold. Uh, it's, it's,
it's a hint at the malevolent
agency of these priests,
and it should point us to the, the true
outrageousness of this, of this speech.
Maybe it's irrationality. We, we already
know that Edward King, of course,
he wasn't killed by the presence
of the Church of England.
He was drowned and the drowning was an
accident. The palm never questions that.
And it was ridiculous to lay his death
at the churches at the churches door.
But the poem nonetheless harbors this,
this wonderfully primitive and
irrational accusation. And, and,
and there's a lapse in logic here.
And this lab should focus our interest
all the more on the urgency that we feel
in Saint Peter's speech. This isn't just
a speech, this is a vitriolic tirade.
This and it gets ugly.
Uh,
Milton needs to get ugly here.
He needs to voice this tirade,
and he needs to write this politically
motivated harangue. And as you,
and as you'll see,
it starts to pick up more and
more enemies as it moves along.
Look at line 119 blind mouths
that's scarce themselves.
Know how to hold a sheep hook or have
learned ought else the least that to the
faithful Herdman art belongs.
The faithful Herdman art enlisted as
is, uh, is a double one. It's the,
it's the Christian art of
ministering to a religious flock.
It's that of the pastor and it's the
more classical art of, of poetry.
And the man against whom Saint Peter's
is really spitting his venom are bad pass
doors in every sense of the word.
They're, they're, they're corrupt,
not only as ministers, but they are also
corrupt as poets. They're bad poets.
Look at line 123.
These are such great and when they list,
okay,
and when they list their
lien and flashy songs,
great on their scrambled
pipes of rich and straw,
I have to read these lines again. And when
they list their lien and flashy songs,
great on their scrambled
pipes of wretched straw,
it seems to be the case that
Milton's made this word up,
this wonderful word
scramble. The only, uh,
and it seems to mean
something like scrawny.
At least that's what the OED tells us.
And the only example that they
can find if the word scramble is,
is Milton's solicitous.
Um,
this last line that I've read seems
itself to have been graded on a honest
granel pipe.
It's,
it's such an unpleasant line and it's
always worth asking yourself what a line
of poetry that is as aggressive,
aggressively unpleasant as this one
is doing in a poem. But this year,
cacophony of the clustered consonants in
this line sets off or has the potential
to set off a powerful,
a powerful cluster of feelings.
The anger here is directed
against the superficial,
the flashy liturgies are read
by the lobby and priests,
but I think it's also
being directed at the,
at the lean and flashy songs that are
being written by Milton's contemporary,
Milton's poetic contemporaries,
his rival poets,
Saint Saint Peter has arrived from heaven
into this poem to express perhaps for
the first time that envy and the anger
that Milton seems successfully to have
suppressed up to this
point. Um, envy and anger,
not only at the state of the,
of the Church of England in the late
1630s, but also the state of poetry.
And uh, in England at this
time. So Saint Peters,
St Peter Concludes with a co it goes on
and he concludes with a couple of that
is as terrifying and it's threaded.
Finality as it is for me,
utterly baffling in its significance.
Look at the last two lines,
but that two handed engine at the doors
stands ready to smile once and smite no
more. Now, we will never know
and don't let anyone ever suggest to
you that you will ever know what Milton
could possibly mean by this deliberately
perplexing image of the two handed
engine at the door.
If you ever want to take a look at the,
and I urge you to the Vario RM commentary
on the poems of John Milton in the CCO
collection, you should peruse it.
It's a massive, wonderful, uh,
multivolume work that catalogs all
of the critical commentary on Milton.
Shorter poems,
um,
up until some point in the 70s and there
are no less than 20 pages devoted to
the critical debate on these two lines.
What the Hell Saint Peter's two
handed engine is what it looks like,
what it tells us,
everything about it.
We have no idea what this
menacing contraption actually
is supposed to look like
or what it's actually intended to signify.
But we can now,
I think with some certainty
that it's not scramble.
It's size matters here and this,
the two handed engine is big and it
works and it's able to put an apocalyptic
and to all to all corruption.
And in fact,
it's able to put something like
an apocalyptic and to all life.
It stands ready to smile
once and smite no more.
Now,
we began this poem with a sense of the
dreary repetitiveness and that opening
phrase, yet once more, yet once more,
but here very close to the poems.
And we have a vision of an end to all
those fruitless exercise is a repetition.
Milton corrects.
It's as if he's correcting the sense
of monotony with which he had begun the
poem and he corrects that.
Uh,
he corrects that sense of monotony
by rewriting that initial phrase,
whatever the two handed engine is,
it will smite once and smite no more.
It's incapable of repeating
itself. Now, I think there's a,
there's a deliberate confusion here about
these lines because they're precise.
Historical significance is, isn't
what's, isn't. What's most significant.
What may be most important here is the,
is the mere fact that Milton
is expressing these political,
these political convictions
at all. The, the,
the speech of the speech
of Saint Peter Seems,
I think in a lot of ways to be a lot more
like a fire and brimstone sermon than
it is a passage,
a passage in a pastoral poem.
And the strangely sermonising tone
that this speech assumes is a,
is I think exactly the point Milton
is able in this speech to combine,
I think,
to combine for the first time the two
associations borne by that Latin word
Pastore.
So in this guys with the mask of Saint
Peter on his Milton's able to be both
poet and minister,
he's investing his rhetorical talent in
an art that's actually doing something.
It's, it's capable of moving
people to action. Or, so
Milton, uh, may have believed,
it says, if Milton is saying, look
at me, I may be a poet. I May, uh,
I may actually, uh, I, I'm,
I'm simply writing a pastoral poem,
but I'm actually doing something in
the world. I'm minister into a flock.
I'm preaching just as my father and just
as all of my Cambridge classmates had
advised me to do.
This outburst allows Melton to solve
what may have seen up to this point,
an insoluble conflict,
the insoluble conflict between the,
the two meanings of the word vocation that
we've been, that we've been exploring.
So this passage is extreme and Milton's
poem wonderfully is perfectly able to
identify it as such. So look, look what
happens next. After the passengers over,
Milton addresses Alphaeus a river God,
the God who was noted for plunging the
course of his river underground in order
to change chase, the new era who's, uh,
who had been turned into a fountain,
um, I'll face is also the god
of erotic pastoral poetry.
It turns out,
and this God has literally
gone underground during the
terrifying appearance of
Saint Peter and it's here, although
we didn't know that God was there.
This is another familiar and
strange feature of this problem.
We didn't know the God was there and
we didn't know he was underground until
Milton tells us that he's coming up.
Now it's here.
Once that speech is over that Milton
can bid Alphaeus return line 132 return,
I'll Fayez the dread voice is
past that shrunk by streams,
the dread voice of the
angry Surmont Milton,
the ministerial Milton has passed.
It has passed and it is past. It's
part of the, it's part of the past.
And it's at this point, and I think
it's importantly not before this point,
that Milton's able to throw himself
fully into that eroticized conjecture,
that catalog of all the flowers,
that that was to be thrown onto the
hearse bearing listed as his body that we
looked at last time.
I,
I mentioned in the last lecture that the
theme is flower passage here of course,
is this is pure fantasy listed as
his body is nowhere to be found. Uh,
and there's, and there's nothing
of course to throw the flowers on,
but I think we can see now a way in which
Milton has permitted himself the
fantasy, the fantasy of this, uh,
of a recovered body. Or as
he says, this is line 153,
he is allowed it's frail thoughts
to dally with false surmise.
Milton can allow himself a literary
indulgence in the rich sensuality of this
passage because he has
mastered the dread voice.
He has mastered the fatherly sternness of,
of Saint Peter.
It's as if Milton, we can think
of Milton is having paid his dues.
He's accomplished as ministerial duty
as a zealous and a politically oriented
poet.
And now he's earned the right.
He's earned the right to
dally with false surmise.
He's earned the right to treat
himself to this absolutely lovely.
What must have been an extraordinary
amount of fun to write the, the,
the lovely catalog of flowers.
It's almost as if the, the,
the flower passages,
Milton's reward for having
written the Saint Peter Passage.
And I'm trying to suggest that Milton's
composition of this poem is actually
doing something for him. That it gets
him somewhere, that it's functional in a,
in a, in a genuine sense. And so, uh,
it's our obligation now to
look at the poems. Conclusion,
where does listen to us leave Milton
look at a lineup. One 83 Milton
imagines listed us in heaven.
Now it's a Christian poem
and then it imagines,
listen to this a little differently
as the genius Loci the, this, the,
the natural classical spirit of the place,
the genius Loci of the Irish scene.
This is line 183.
Henceforth thou art the genius of the
shore in dye large recompense and shalt be
good to all that wander
in that parallel is flood
period,
thus saying the uncouth Swain to the
yolks and reels while the still mourn went
out with sandals gray. He
touched the tender stops, uh,
various quills with eager thought
warbling his doric lay and now the son had
stretched out all the hills.
And now was dropped into the western
Bay at last tea rose and twitched his
mantle blue tomorrow to
fresh woods and pastures new.
Okay.
Um,
I want to draw your attention to line 186
this is the line that begins the poems
final verse paragraph,
and it has to be one of the most amazing
moments in all of English literature.
Thus saying these five words,
thus saying the uncouth Swain.
Yeah.
Okay. What are we being
told here? This poem,
this entire poem before this point
hasn't been sung by John Milton at all.
We naturally thought that
it was the poet John Milton,
who was speaking the first
185 lines of the poem.
We naturally assume that it was Milton
himself who was describing the his
college friendship with
listed as Edward Edward King.
We naturally assume that
the poet was speaking
even with even behind the pastoral
mask because we'd been given no idea
whatsoever of any alternative to the poets
responsibility for all of these words
being uttered over the course of
this admittedly very long poem,
but with little of do,
this just happens.
Milton suddenly and unexpectedly
shatters all of our,
all of our assumptions. He tells us that
everything that we read up to this point
that has been spoken by,
uh,
everything that we read up to this
point has been spoken by a third person.
Narrator. We didn't know this has
been spoken by the uncouth Swain,
a rustic shepherd.
Everything that we had thought that
Milton was telling us in the lyric present
telling us directly now suddenly gets
shoved back into the narrative past thus
saying the uncouth Swain,
the past tense is important there and
that this is the first moment right now
they'll sing the uncouth and this is the
first moment that the poet John Melton
is actually speaking in his own voice
and he's speaking directly to us.
We don't actually hear John
Nelson until we hear this line,
thus saying the uncooked Swain.
Well,
we should be shocked.
And I think beyond that,
we have every right to feel a little
bit betrayed because Milton quite simply
has,
and he's doing this deliberately,
he has just violated an
important law concerning,
uh,
we could think of it as the contractual,
the contractual relation
that a writer with his,
with his reader when there's a speaker
of a poem who was not to be confused with
the poet himself.
There is typically a framing device and
you can easily imagine Milton employing
a framing device here. Um, he could
have begun a listed this with this,
with something like a description
of the uncouth Swain, Oh,
let me tell you about this uncouth Swain.
And then he could tell us the mournful
lay that the uncouth Swain sang.
And then he could say, thus saying
the uncouth Swain, uh, there would be,
uh, an opening, a framing device,
and then of course an end frame device.
But Milton's framing device in, listen,
it's only frames the end of the
phone. It's asymmetrical. And,
and I think we're fully
entitled to ask why,
why Milton waits for the last eight lines
of his poem to tell us that there's a
difference.
There's a difference between
the poet and the speaker.
Why hadn't Milton pressed on the
this possible distinction earlier?
And the answer to the question,
I think gets at the very
heart of the meaning of this,
of this log.
And I think the answer may involve the
possibility that at the beginning of the
poem,
there simply wasn't a clear distinction
between the poet and this being super
speaker [inaudible].
It's as if the distinction between
John Milton and the speaker of, of,
of Lucentis wasn't really operative.
There wasn't an uncouth Swain,
uh, at the beginning. And you'll, you'll,
you'll, you'll remember that I mentioned
several minutes ago that Milton
appears literary historians,
I think I've rightly seen the Milton
who had written listed us as a different
figure than the one than the poet
before having written lists of this.
Milton seems to have accomplished
something in writing lists and us as if he
almost as if,
almost as if he accomplishes that over
the course of this berry poem and one of
the things that he's accomplished,
his,
his ability to see himself as someone
who has accomplished something. He,
he's just written this poem and instead
of this continual amp aunt is a patient
of writing something great.
Uh,
Milton is able to look back and find
closure in something already written.
And at the very end of the poem,
the uncouth Swain rose and twitched his
mantle blue tomorrow to fresh woods and
passengers knew. And you get
an image of Milton here. Uh,
twitching is blue mantle his cape over
his shoulder and dusting his hands and
letting us know that that's
over. He's finished. He's,
he has completed this lyric poem.
He's,
he's finished with his pastoral,
perhaps even he has completed the
youthful phase of his literary career.
Now we began listen to us with an image
of a poet who could only write this poem.
This is what we were told
with forced fingers. Rude.
This was an act of composing. And
the poet had to be forced to, to,
to press this lyric out of himself.
But by the end of the poem, um,
we progressed from the image
of forced fingers rude.
This is an argument that's
been made brilliantly by the,
by the critic Peter Sacks, the author
of a book called the English level LNG.
We've PR progressed from
the image of forced fingers,
rude to an image of the poet who touched
the tender stops of various quills.
The poet's fingers by the end of listed
as aren't, aren't forced or rude.
They're capable of these extraordinarily
delicate feats of dexterity.
And that's because the poet has mastered
his touch and this tactile mastery,
a tests to something remarkable that's
happened over the course of the poem
somewhere below the surface of the poem,
somewhere between the lines,
Milton has mastered his poetic touch,
perhaps because Milton
himself has been touched.
Let me remind you of that other
intrusive moment in the poem.
The the moment when a figure whose
presence we hadn't been aware of suddenly
made a suddenly asserted himself.
That was of course Vivas Apollo,
the great god of the Sun.
And the God of poetry who touched the
trembling ears of the ambitious young
Milton much as he had
a century or so before,
a couple of centuries before,
uh,
touched the ears of the ambitious young
Virgil Apollo had touched Milton away in
a way that I think we can actually
measure. But by the end of this poem,
because Milton at the conclusion of
listen to us seems to have assumed the
authority of, of, of Apollo.
It's as if he's become a Paulo as he
himself takes over the action of touching
that the speaker has internalized
the authority of the god of poetry.
First he was touched and now he touches,
he touches the,
the stops a various quills.
Look at the final,
look at the final lines and now the son
had stretched out all the hills and now
was dropped into the western
Bay at last tea rose and touched
no at last.
T rose and twitched his mantle blue
tomorrow to fresh woods and pastures.
Now I,
I'm,
I'm interested in this temporal clause
and now Nelson shows us he's fully escape
from the repetitiveness of the yet
once more beginning, this code is,
suggests something like a victory
over all of those worries of,
of unpreparedness as the,
as the worried rhetoric of not yet there.
It gives way to a much more confident
language of present completion than now
and now the son had stretched out all
hills and now was dropped into the western
bay.
Atlast he rose
last,
he rose.
This is it's last d rose that
last who rose who wrote the son,
the son that was just dropped into
the west or the uncouth Swain.
This is my question to you now. We,
we learned of course in the, by the,
by the second half of this line that it
has to be the uncouth Swain who weren't
rose and twitched,
his mantle blue.
But for a moment the he in line 192 seems
to be able to refer to either the poet
or the sun.
Maybe it could refer to either the poet
or the sun throughout the entire line.
If you think of the mantle blue was being
the actual sky that the son is able to
twitch over his shoulder, I dunno. Um,
it's at this point of
a possible confusion,
at least a momentary provisional
confusion that we know that the poet has
identified with the son.
He's absorbed the touching authority
of Phoebus Apollo, the god of the Sun.
Milton.
Why is that important?
Milton can no longer be chided be
criticized by Phoebus because he's become
Phoebus
this,
this momentary switch off between the
sun and the poet is just one of this
poem's many,
many substitutions you saw earlier.
See Peter Making a related set of
substitutions and it was crazy.
Peter was lamenting Edward King's death
and he claimed that he would gladly have
spared an entire slew of
corrupt Anglican priests.
He would gladly have sacrificed them in
order to keep the much more virtuous and
pure,
listen us a gruesome proposal,
but it's a group in proposal that suggests
that a primitive desire for a quid
pro quo,
and it's this seem desire for some kind
of sacrificial substitution that I think
is fueling the poem's ending.
That dynamic of the entire poem is
one of sacrifice and recompense.
Edward King gave his life and he's
recompensed by his new status of the,
as the genius of the shore.
But John Milton is also recompensed,
but and,
and by the weird sacrificial logic that
Saint Peter is already sketched out for
us, you can see a really disturbing way
in which Milton has benefited as well.
It's as if listened to this has died so
that Milton could live to become a great
poet listed as his untimely death
seems to enable Milton to master.
He's owned fears of untimeliness listed.
This is death. This is, remember,
this is the poem that
Milton didn't want to ride.
He was forced to write it a
mill. Listen, this is death,
allows the uncouth Swain
to grow up to move on.
And the last date lines announced
the course of this new poet's life.
Um,
the announces the fact that this,
this poets course in life is
about to undergo a drastic change.
And in fact, by a graphically,
this is what happens to Milton.
Finally,
John Milton leaves his father's house.
He moves out and he goes on. And of
course he's still being supported, uh,
quite generously by his
father. Nonetheless, he goes
on an extended tour, um,
through France and Italy,
but he manages to discard that youthful,
that uncouth affection for chastity
that had been such a part of his
imagination. And he marries, um,
a young woman named Mary Powell.
Now it's still going to be another 25
years before Milton writes the great epic.
But Milton will no longer express the
same degree of anxiety about under
preparation to write the great
epic. And in fact, uh, this is,
this is an argument that's been made a
number of times and I think there's a lot
of sense to it.
The last eight lines of listed us are
written in a very specific rhyme form the,
the Italian scheme of the Ottava rema
and it's the Ottava Rima in which all of
the great Italian romance epics by poets,
uh,
favorite poets of Milton's like
Ariosto and Taso had been written.
The appearance of this semi epic rhyme
scheme here at the end of Milton Milton's
poem suggests is readiness.
And he's ready only here at the end of
to us to embark on the epic project.
Okay. Quickly, I'm going to ask you to
turn to the very beginning of Lucentis,
page 120 in the Hughes,
so listen,
this was published along as you know
with the along with the other poems about
Edward King in 1637 but Milton himself
publishes the poem a second time and his
own volume of poems that he publishes in
1645 and it's for this second printing
that Milton ads,
the head note that you see here that
now begins the poem in this Monety,
the author be whales,
a learned friend,
unfortunately drowned in his passage
from Chester on the Irish sees 1637 it's
interesting that Milton certainly begins
this headnote with suggesting directly
to us that it's Milton speaking
and not a fictional uncouth Swain,
but that that aside,
let me continue on the,
I received 1637 and bio occasion for
tells the ruin of our corrupted clergy.
Then in their height,
eight years after its initial composition,
Milton looks back at this allergy,
rereads it and picks out the Saint
Peter Passage on the corrupted clergy.
Is that specific feature of the poem
worth singling out and introducing.
And of course in a lot of ways this is
just good marketing. Since the poems,
initial appearance,
the institution of episcopacy or church
hierarchy has been seriously eroded.
The, the, the,
the first English civil war has already
broken out setting puritans like Milton
against the royalists and the supporters
of the state control of the church like
the king and like the king's dread
Archbishop of Canterbury William Laud.
Um, when Milton writes this
little head note in 1645,
archbishop laud has been executed.
Um,
he's been sacrificed to the puritan cause
and Milton reasonably alerts is reader
to the timeliness of a lot of the material
that would be covered in this poem.
But this headnote goes a lot
further simply than that.
And Bio quetsion foretells the ruin
of our corrupted clergy Milton was,
is this is outrageous.
He's actually claiming that this poem
had been prophetic [inaudible] listed as
foretold the ruin of the clergy.
And it's possible that Milton
is actually suggesting,
I think that this poem
helped bring that ruin about,
you know,
that Milton had been entertaining this
fantasy of becoming a great biblical
prophet like Isaiah.
As early as the naitivity out.
He'd seen himself as a
Jeremiah or as an Isiah.
And there were all those
early gestures of prophecy,
but now he's able to tell us that
he has already become prophetic.
He throws his high per a prophetic
talents into the construction of the Saint
Peter Speech. And in 1645 historical
circumstances being what they were,
he was able to look back at this passage
and actually claim that it had been a
genuinely prophetic utterance.
Um,
he's made good on all of his promises.
Of course,
it's a sleazy move for Milton to have
made to claim that he had actually
prophesied, let's say, the execution
of our archbishop laud. Um,
but Milton will capitalize and exploit
any evidence he can possibly find to
assure himself that he is on the,
the appropriate path to become
the great prophetic poet, um,
that he knows he is entitled to become
and that he has been chosen to become.
Finally,
Milton has revised and undone the
anticipatory logic of the great career
narrative.